Every year on December 24th, children from all over the world come up with milk and biscuits.
Bar looked to be able to attract a fat-grand grandfather into the house and leave a gift before he got into the neighbor's house.
How was this strange custom born?
Perhaps the most blame for you is Nordic. The winter there is cold and black and melancholy.
The coldest and darkest is the winter solstice on December 21 or 22.
The sun only rises for an hour, emitting some faint light, and some places are at night.
These people who have been taken away from the sun invented magic to visit them and make them comfortable with gifts and blessings.
These magical spells include elves, gods, goats, etc., two of which have a special impact on modern stories.
The first one is St Nick in the Netherlands. St. Nick is very thin and even harsh.
But the gift will still be brought to the children in early December. He is red and white,
Holding a staff, like a bishop. His mount is a horse called Amerigo, and the children of the Netherlands will leave carrots for it.
Saint Nick is called Sinterklaas in Dutch.
The second place is England's Father Christmas. Christmas dad is a big man,
Wearing a funny pagan green dress with a sacred corolla on top.
Traditionally, he is not very close to children and gifts, and has more to do with food, wine and celebrations.
Perhaps the most well-known is this: he is one of the three ghosts of Christmas that threaten the miser.
After Europe began to colonize, St. Nick, Christmas Dad and other magical geniuses gradually merged.
This explains why the US version has many of these names. Santa Claus is Americanized Sinterklaas.
But he is also known as Saint Nick, Christmas Dad and Kris Kringle from Germany.
Different spells in the old days have become the same in the new world over time.
Just like other ancient legends.
For example, the New York poem "Christmas Eve", which appeared in 1823.
It laid the tradition of Santa Claus landing from the roof and filling up socks with toys.
However, this Santa Claus is an elf, just like other Santa Claus from Northern Europe. He is very small,
Driving a small reindeer sleigh - this makes sense.
After all, his work included drilling into the chimney.
In addition, Santa did not appear in the poem. The original name of the poem was called "The Visit of St. Nick."
In the 19th century, the fat old Santa became a standard among American writers.
In the United States, he not only got the power of the elves but also got his wife.
By the 20th century, Santa became the iconic image of the present. It is worth mentioning that,
Contrary to what is generally believed, Coca-Cola did not package Santa Claus into the logo of the company.
Instead, in 1931, the red and white Santa Claus was used directly in the off-season to promote drinks.
Although I didn’t shoot a full range of gift ads for Santa Claus,
Coca-Cola may indeed have brought the only true Santa as a brand into the minds of thousands of people.
It has made Santa Claus take root in many countries where there is no winter gift tradition.
Santa Claus in the United States in turn affected his relatives in Northern Europe. They always become more and more similar to their American relatives,
No matter if the locals are happy.
Especially in the UK, Christmas dad has completely turned into Santa Claus.
So many British people don't even know that they have been different.
However, in the Netherlands, St. Nick still managed to hold on to the fact that he was an independent magician.
Regarding the modern Santa Claus, it is worth arguing, especially the details that deserve to be debated by various countries.
Where does he live?
At the end of the century, his home was located in the northern pole of the aurora.
Although this is the best choice from a diplomatic point of view, but since then
The North magnetic pole slipped into the ocean from the Arctic ice sheet. That is not a good place to open a toy factory.
Therefore, Canada claims that his toy workshop is located somewhere in Nunavut and gave Santa a zip code.
And - no joke - Canadian legal citizenship.
The American response is that the Arctic does not refer to the obvious uninhabitable ice sheet.
It refers to the border town of the Arctic, Alaska.
Denmark claims that Santa Claus lives in their former colony, Greenland. Greenland did not agree with it surprisingly.
The Nordic countries are arguing about the exact location of Santa Claus, but Finland
With Rovaniemi in the Arctic Circle, it is obviously more advantageous.
If you need evidence, you can actually visit Santa, as well as elves, toys, reindeer and post office.
This makes the Finnish statement seem invulnerable. Santa can be seen even during the non-Christmas season.
However, no matter where his base is, Santa always has the means to travel around the world overnight.
And send out all the gifts... and eat all the cookies.